a man that is of copernicus's opinion
that this earth of ours is a planet
carried round and enlightened by the sun
like the rest of them cannot but
sometimes have a fancy that it's not
improbable that the rest of the planets
have their dress and furniture nay and
their inhabitants too as well as this
earth of ours
especially if he considers the later
discoveries made since copernicus's time
of the attendance of jupiter and saturn
and the hilly countries in the moon
which are an argument of a relation and
kin between our earth and them
first it is more than probable that the
bodies of the planets are solid like
that of our earth and that they don't
want what we call gravity that virtue
which like a lodestone attracts whatever
is near the body to its center
and that they have such a quality their
very figure is a proof for their
roundness proceeds only from an equal
pressure of all their parts tending to
the same center nay more we are so
skillful nowadays is to be able to tell
how much more or less the gravitation in
jupiter or saturn is than here
but now to carry the search further let
us see by what steps we must rise to the
attaining some knowledge in the more
private secrets concerning the state and
furniture of these new earths
and first how likely is it that they may
be stocked with plants and animals as
well as we
this video was sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
question who's the first person to
discover america was it a columbus b
junger or c life erickson that's right
none of them there were people already
there but the first europeans were
indeed the vikings and so a great
recommendation from magellan's
collection this week is the norse an
arctic mystery which dives into the
fascinating exploration of america half
a century before columbus
magellan tv have supported this channel
for more than a year and they are a
great choice if you like documentaries
and want more context to our videos they
have more than 3 000 works to choose
from
and now you can take advantage of an
exclusive offer 30 off an annual
membership this gives you an entire year
for less than 3.50 a month you can
simply click on the link in the
description to claim your discounted
membership today
thanks
how should we allow the planets nothing
but vast deserts lifeless and inanimate
stalks and stones and deprive them of
all those creatures that more plainly
speak of their divine architect we
should sink them below the earth in
beauty and dignity a thing that no
reason will permit as i said before
[Music]
well then and now that we have gained
the point for them and the planets may
be allowed some bodies capable of moving
themselves
and these
are animals
now for fear of starving these poor
creatures we must have plants you know
and as for their growth and nourishment
it is no doubt the same as ours seeing
they have the same sun to warm and
enliven them as ours have
but perhaps somebody may say we conclude
too fast
why must they be of the same nature with
ours
nature seems to cause variety in her
works and may have made them widely
different from ours either in their
manner or matter of growth in their
outward shape or their inward contextual
she may have made them such as neither
our understanding nor imagination can
conceive
[Music]
who doubts but the god if he had pleased
might have made the animals in america
and other distant countries nothing like
ours
and nature you know affects variety yet
we see he has not done it
they have indeed some difference in
their shape and his fit they should to
distinguish the plants and animals of
those countries from ours who live on
this side of the earth
but even in this variety there is an
agreement an exact correspondence in
figure and shape the same ways of growth
and new productions and of continuing
their own kind
their animals have feet and wings like
ours and like ours have heart lungs guts
and the parts serving to generation
whereas all these things as well with
them as us might if it had pleased
infinite wisdom have been ordered in a
very different way it is more probable
that all the difference there is between
us and them springs from the greater or
less distance and influence from that
fountain of heat and life the sun which
will cause a difference not so much in
their form and shape as in their matter
and contextual thus we see that by the
means of water the plants grow blossom
and bear fruit and by the addition of
that
only
that the planets are not without water
is made not improbable by the late
observations for about jupiter are
observed some spots of a darker hue than
the rest of his body which by their
continual change show themselves to be
clouds for the spots of jupiter which
belong to him and never remove from him
are quite different from these being
sometimes for a long time not to be seen
for these clouds
that they have plants and animals i
think i have fully proved and by the
same argument of their not being
inferior to our earth they must have as
great a variety of both as we have
what this is will be best known to him
that considers the different ways our
animals make use of in moving from one
place to another
[Music]
which may be reduced i think to these
either that they walk upon two feet or
four or like insects upon six nay
sometimes hundreds or that they fly in
the air bearing up and wonderfully steer
themselves with their wings or creep
upon the ground without feet or by a
violent spring in their bodies or
paddling with their feet cut themselves
away in the waters
i don't believe nor can i conceive that
there should be any other way than those
mentioned
the animals then in the planets must
make use of one or more of these like
our amphibious birds which can swim in
water as well as walk on land or fly in
the air or like our crocodiles and sea
horses must be mongrels between land and
water there can no other method be
imagined but one of these
but when we come to meddle with the
shape of these creatures and consider
the incredible variety that is even in
those of the different parts of this
earth and that america has some which
are nowhere else to be found i must then
confess that i think it beyond the force
of imagination to arrive at any
knowledge in the matter or reach
probability concerning the figures of
these planetary animals
but perhaps it may be asked as well
concerning brutes as rational creatures
whether they are proportionally larger
or less than ours for if the magnitude
of the planets was to be the standard of
their measure there would be animals in
jupiter 10 or 15 times larger than
elephants
and is much longer than our whales and
then their men must be goliaths in
respect of our pygmy ships
now though i don't see any so great
absurdity in this as to make it
impossible yet there is no reason to
think it is really so seeing nature has
not always tied ourselves to these rules
which we have thought more convenient
for her
for example the magnitude of the planets
is not answerable to their distances
from the sun but mars though more remote
is far less than venus and jupiter turns
around his axis in 10 hours when the
earth which is much less than him spends
24
but since nature perhaps somebody will
say has not observed such irregularity
in the proportion of things for all what
we know we may have a race of pygmies
about the bigness of frogs and mice
possessed of the planets
[Music]
then the necessity and such observations
of marking down the epochs or accounts
of time and of transmitting them to
posterity will force us to grant them
the art of writing
i won't say the same with ours which is
commonly used but i dare affirm not more
ingenious or easy for how much more
ready in expedies is our way than by
that multitude of characters used in
china and how vastly preferable to knots
tied in chords or the pictures in use
among the barbarous people of mexico and
peru there's no nation in the world but
has some way or other of writing and
marking down their thoughts so that it's
no wonder if the planetarians had been
taught it by that great school mistress
necessity and apply it to the study of
astronomy and other sciences
but somebody might perhaps object and
not without reason that the planetarians
are just as likely to be destitute of
all refined knowledge just as the
americans were before they had commerce
with the europeans
for if one considers the ignorance of
those nations and of others in asia and
africa equally barbarous it will appear
as if the main design of the creator in
placing men upon the earth was that they
might
live
and in a just sense of all the blessings
and pleasure they enjoy worship the
fountain of their happiness
but that some bold fellows have leapt
over the bounds of nature and made
searches into those forbidden depths
only out of an affectation of knowing
more than they were made for
we have shown before the necessary
dependence and connection not only of
geometry and arithmetic but of
mechanical arts and instruments with
this science
this leads us naturally to the inquiry
how they can use these instruments and
engines for the observation of the stars
how they can write down such their
observations and perform other things
which we do with our hands
i know an ancient philosopher laid such
stress upon the use and convenience of
the hands that he made no scruple to
affirm they were the cause and
foundation of all our knowledge by which
i suppose he meant no more than that
without their help and assistance men
could never arrive to the improvement of
their minds in natural knowledge and
truly not without reason for suppose
instead of them they had hooves like
horses or bullocks given them they might
have laid indeed the model and design of
them in their head but they would never
have been able to build cities and
houses
they would have been void of all
knowledge and memory and indeed would
have been but one degree distant from
brute beasts
what could we imagine or invent that
could be so exactly accommodated to all
the designed uses as hands are
shall we give them an elephant's
proboscis it is true these beasts can
lay hold of or throw anything can take
up even the smallest things from the
ground and can perform such admirable
feats with it that it has not very
improperly been called their hand though
indeed it is nothing but a nose somewhat
longer than ordinary nor do birds show
less art and design in the use of their
bills for the picking up of meat and the
wonderful composure of their nests but
all this is nothing to those
conveniences the hand is so admirably
suited to
nothing to that amazing contrivance in
its capacity of being stretched or
contracted or turned to any part as
occasion shall require and then to pass
by that nice sense that the ends of the
fingers are endued with even to the
feeling and distinguishing most sorts of
bodies in the dark what wisdom and art
is showed in the disposition of the
thumb and fingers so as to take up or
keep fast hold of anything we please
either then the gentleman that lived
there must have hands or something
equally convenient which is no easy
matter or else we must say that nature
has been kinder not only to us but even
to squirrels and monkeys than them
that they have feat scarce anyone can
doubt that does but consider what we
said just now of the different methods
of progression which it's hard to
imagine can be performed in any other
way than those we have recounted
except what is not very probable if they
live in a society as i shall show they
do they have found out the art of flying
in some of these worlds
astronomy as we said before could never
subsist without the writing down of
observations nor could the art of
writing any more than the carpenters and
founders ever be found out except in a
society of reasonable creatures where
the necessities of life forced upon them
invention
so that what i promised to prove follows
from hence namely that the planetarians
must in this be like us that they
maintain a society and fellowship with
and afford mutual assistances in helps
to one another hereupon we must allow
them a settled not a wandering scythian
way of living but what then shall they
have everything else proper for such a
manner of living granted them to shall
they have their governors houses cities
trade and bartering
why not when even the barbarous people
of america and other places were at
their first discovery found to have
somewhat of that nature in use among
them i won't say that things must be the
same there as they are here we have many
that may very well be spared among
rational creatures and were designed
only for the preservation of society
from all injury
and for the curbing of those men who
make an ill use of their reason to the
detriment of others perhaps in the
planets they have such plenty in
affluence of all good things as they
neither need nor desire to steal from
one another perhaps they may be so just
and good as to be a perpetual peace and
never to lie and wait for or take away
the life of their neighbor perhaps they
may not know what anger or hatred are
which we too at our cost and misery know
here too well
but still it's more likely that they
have such a medley as we such a mixture
of good with bad of wise with fools of
war with peace
and want not that school mistress of
arts poverty
thus i have heaped together all these
late discoveries of our earth and now
though perhaps some of them may be
common to the planetarians with us
yet that they should have all of them
is not credible it is a very ridiculous
opinion that the common people have got
among them that it is impossible a
rational soul should dwell in any other
shape than ours
and yet as silly as tis it has been the
occasion of many philosophers allowing
the gods no other shape this can proceed
from nothing but weakness ignorance and
prejudice of man as well as that two of
humane figure being the handsomest and
most excellent of all others when indeed
it's nothing but a being accustomed to
that figure that makes us think so and a
conceit that we and all other animals
naturally have that no shape or color
can be so good as our own
[Music]
you